That again.
[Music]
We're looking for people that are
willing to sell their homes and to come
and be amongst the community and to
follow me. Believe me when I say this,
you guys are not ready for what you're
about to watch. I wish really with heart
to be there for you, to listen to you,
console you and above all to give you
all my supports.
Upon this I shall live, upon this I
shall die and upon this I shall be
resurrected again. We have here if you
believe that this is the call of the
cotton. If you truly believe that and
you pledged allegiance to that, if you
believe that I am the kim of the family
of Muhammad that all of the prophets and
the messengers wished to be with and
wanted to return to this world to
support. If you truly believe that, then
there shouldn't be any price that you
wouldn't pay in order to come and
support me and to help me carry this
burden. And Jesus said it. He said,
"Whoever wants to follow me has to be
willing to carry their cross on their
back like me." Right? So that's the
that's the thing. And thank you so much
for that. I would like to testify also
that there is no worthier cause than
this and that all of us here are
absolutely happy that we're supporting
this and you. There's no other way to
support God other than to come and
support you. The information that I
found on this guy is absolutely insane.
head on over to Life Reacts to watch the
full
documentary. And I I honestly have no
words. I thought this was going to be a
quick, short, and simple video about
this so-called Antichrist, and the stuff
that I found just blew me away. I could
do a part two, three, and four on all of
the stuff that I found out about this
guy. It is so overwhelming.
[Music]